[Música]
en directo a hoy hablamos de las
multitudinarias protestas que se
produjeron en varias ciudades peruanas
son trabajadores del sector minero que
se manifestaron para exigirle al
gobierno de pedro castillo que
solucionen la disputa entre los
responsables de la mina de cobre de las
bambas y las comunidades de la zona esto
ha hecho que el yacimiento lleve cerrado
50 días los responsables del lugar
aseguran que unos 8000 trabajadores se
han visto afectados por la disputa
conectamos con francisco zacarías
corresponsal de france 24 en lima
francisco cuáles son las exigencias de
los trabajadores mineros
buenas noches por tercera vez los
trabajadores de la mina las bambas
marcharon por las calles de tres
ciudades lima cusco y arequipa para
exigirle al gobierno del presidente
pedro castillo que ponga orden en el
contorno de la mina las bambas y se haga
respetar el estado de derecho y se
garantice el empleo de los trabajadores
desde hace 50 días comunidades indígenas
bloquean las operaciones del yacimiento
que es manejado por la empresa china m/m
y produce el 2 por ciento del cobre en
el mundo pero cómo se produce este
conflicto las comunidades indígenas
existen que
señalan que existirían supuestos
compromisos incumplidos por la empresa
esto pone en peligro el empleo de 8 mil
trabajadores
eric ramos secretario del sindicato de
trabajadores mineros él me dijo que se
reunió con el primer ministro aníbal
torres y que tras la reunión que llevó
más o menos una hora éste le prometió
que el estado intervendrá para
solucionar el conflicto
francisco qué repercusiones generan pero
este conflicto entre comunidades
indígenas y la compañía minera de las
bambas
diversos expertos señalan que estos
conflictos le hacen perder al perú
exportación de cobre por más de 460
millones de dólares y asimismo el país
deja de recibir la recaudación de
impuestos por más de 100 millones de
dólares por su parte la defensoría del
pueblo ha señalado que existen 209
conflictos en el perú 87 ellos están
relacionados con empresas mineras esta
situación también golpea negativamente
al turismo en el sector se advierte que
los visitantes extranjeros antes de
venir al perú están tratando de elegir
otro destino de sudamérica con el temor
de que sus vacaciones puedan verse
interrumpidas por eventuales protestas
que casi a diario se registran en este
país